join me now Monica Crowley for me
assistant Secretary of Treasury for
public affairs and Lee zeldin former New
York congressman and gubernatorial
candidate great to have you both on the
program this morning I said Monica just
a moment ago that I was going to return
to those policies of the bide
Administration that serve as incentive I
want you to watch this clip if you would
of Joe Biden at the Congressional
Hispanic caucus last night saying
exactly what he plans to do that in my
estimation Monica will only continue to
serve as a magnet for this problem
listen to this
we're significantly expanding legal
Pathways for entry so businesses can get
the workers they need I'm also directing
my team to make historic increase in the
number of refugees admitted from Latin
America we've launched Outreach
campaigns helping over a million
eligible migrants apply for work permits
and we're accelerating the process for
work permit application right now Monica
he's asking more illegal immigrants to
claim Asylum and get jobs in America
yeah he slurred his way through that
statement but the incentives are very
obvious uh to the American people but
also to people around the world who want
to come into the United States and do it
illegally he's made that very clear look
for all the people will who talk about
well why doesn't Joe Biden have a plan
to deal with the out of control border
and these massive waves of illegal
immigrants coming into the country this
is the plan you know any normal
politician when they're seeing the
negative Fallout you know the negative
economic humanitarian and National
Security implications of this wide open
border for nearly three years now any
normal president would have corrected
the course changed the policy we have
not seen one second of that he has not
changed the policy at all so this is the
plan the plan is to flood the country
you know the old Communists radicals
cloud and Piven talked about the most
effective way to destroy the United
States was to overwhelm her systems and
what better way to do it than to have a
wide open border where you have millions
of illegal immigrants coming into the
country bringing tsunamis of crime drugs
disease the massive strain on all of our
resources from Medical Care to education
this is the deliberate destruction of
the country yeah in Lee every politician
just about who is affected by this
problem including very prominent
Democrats like right here in New York
city mayor Eric Adams are saying the
system is overwhelmed to Monica's point
and New York by the way I mean I have a
hard time extending sympathy to New York
as someone from Texas or anywhere along
the southern border but New York is now
absorbing hundreds of thousands of
illegal immigrants
and the governor of New York was calling
for this a couple years ago you had
Democratic elected officials cheering on
President Biden when he was instituting
this plan as as you and Monica have been
pointing out this is on purpose no
border no country more Democrats are
realizing that no border no re-election
you can't lecture the American public
about bionomics National Security and
homeland security health care trial
trafficking combating Fentanyl and the
list goes on if you're going to be
deliberately implementing this policy at
the border I think that this is an
existential threat not just for many
challenges for our country on the
substance and the policy but politically
it's a nightmare so it doesn't make much
sense especially as 24 gets closer
you both have said something so
intelligent tonight that I just want to
underline it from both of you Monica
you're absolutely right this is not a
policy failure this is a policy success
for the Biden Administration this is the
execution of a policy and Lee there's no
Nation there's no nation state without a
border we're watching the destruction on
purpose successfully of the nation-state
of the United States thank you both
Monica and Lee for being with us tonight
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now